chadwick's unexpected death at the
height of his career brought an
outpouring of tributes from his marvel
family last night
during an abc special with robin roberts
it's a tough loss
he is that generation defining actor
always hard working always a smile on
his face there's a void
now there will forever
be an irreplaceable piece missing from
our marvel family
[Music]
in 2017 chadwick starred as the late
supreme court justice thurgood marshall
from now on we claim it as our own
during production he grew incredibly
close to marshall co-stars
sterling k brown and josh gad
we hung out we hung out we hung out
we're the instigator of the dancing was
like i grieved
this loss he was just a good dude
there aren't words to express
what an amazing human being chadwick
boseman was
i won't let you down yeah i know you
won't
clearly chadwick left a lasting
impression with so many of his fellow
actors
including 42 co-star harrison ford we
like each other a lot man
i text him sometimes he still responds
to my texts
today ford tells e.t quote his
intelligence personal dignity and deep
commitment
elevated the stories he told
what's up perhaps chadwick's closest
co-star was black panther's michael b
jordan
it was important i think for michael and
i to buy into being in this movie
together
we're tied together to a certain degree
forever it's like muhammad ali joe
frazier
uh because these two characters are
essentially two sides of the same coin
e.t has learned jordan is quote
struggling and trying to comprehend the
loss and figure out the best way
to honor his legacy interestingly their
careers first
intersected way back in 2003
chadwick was cast to play susan lucci's
stepson on all my children
but ultimately was let go michael was
his replacement
came we saw we kicked something we had a
chance to talk about it and it was like
we had a good laugh
laugh about it so we were actually
wondering when we would actually
when everybody else was going to figure
it out